oh my if you're having a bad day or
feeling kind of shitty these are Packers
being our Packers should change
[Music]
imagine the feeling of constantly
falling backward while trying to read
the credits of Star Wars and Mandarin
during a wildfire were getting broken up
with and trying to talk your way back
into the good graces but your thoughts
are suffocating your mind is blank this
is what it feels like to have anxiety
but you already knew that if you here to
figure out how to cure it how is it
possible to turn such a shitshow into
something good this is one of my most
asked questions in the comments and my
DMS about mental health therefore today
is a really special episode oh by the
way what do you think of my new studio
[Applause]
[Music]
let's just cut straight to the India how
do I overcome the shitty Feeny pose weed
alcohol ice baths hi Alaska and the
Amazon sure I've done most of them in an
attempt to silence the chaos but the
Cure isn't outside head
it's rather inside up let me elaborate
about four to five years ago I started
experiencing the most intense sensation
of darkness out of no way I just started
feeling really sad when on the outside
my life seemed great it seemed perfect I
had a car friends family a roof over my
head but none of that mattered I I
couldn't feel it much gonna have a
figurative sense it was like I couldn't
see color anymore and after speaking to
a professional I figured out that I have
depression which then turned into
anxiety and I kind of spent the next few
years from then behaving like I had no
manners I couldn't look people in the
eyes I couldn't speak to people
correctly I couldn't attend social
events and I was going like what is
wrong with me I wish that I didn't have
this inside it felt like I was screaming
with vulnerability that I couldn't show
that on the outside and I felt extremely
shameful and the most terrifying thing
about it all is that people on the
outside didn't realize that there was
anything wrong so so generally with with
mental health you end up struggling
alone this is until I realized two
things one to be completely present the
chaos can indeed be silenced but you
want to be able to use the chaos as a
superpower a magic wand for the creative
mind
the best metaphor for this is surfing
the ocean creates this pandemonium and
we ride that shot we don't try
controllers or tame the list but rather
flow with it
[Music]
[Music]
this removes anxiety entirely for that
moment in time people trained tirelessly
through cognitive behavioral therapy to
get this right but it's actually really
easy you don't think about what's gonna
happen in a few moments time you don't
think about yesterday all you think
about is now this becomes easier the
more uncomfortable or incredibly
breathtaking the situation therefore
challenge yourself for something anxiety
is just the fear of the [ __ ] that
doesn't exist yet and in my favorite
part number two which is using your
disposition to your advantage to
transcend through the norm to stand out
through your uniqueness to create art
that speaks consciously to people and
that starts long-term conversation this
is my secret potion it's the ability to
think slightly deeper to be more
connected on an empathetic level my
YouTube channel is nothing but a visual
diary of me answering my own unanswered
questions as I travel through my life I
really wouldn't be doing anything else
in the world right now no matter what
the offer I am living my own dream
I found my ability to be able to be so
pro mental health this way if what I've
been saying resonates with you and you
think that you may be struggling with
your mental health you need to speak to
a professional first and and I totally
get it with anxiety and depression the
last thing you want to do is pick up the
phone and go and see someone
therefore there are sites online that
make it a lot easier there's been a lot
of speculation around better hope calm
and my team and myself we've done tons
of research to look into it from my side
I don't see anything wrong with having
the ability to be able to speak to
somebody about what's happening so
freely and just to be able to event and
share your feelings
I really wish the side like better hope
was around when I was struggling
I'm not gonna speak about any more and
if you are keen go check out the link
I'm gonna put it in the top line in my
description and I really think that you
can benefit other than that
don't forget your awesome brew and I'll
see you next week with
[Music]